hi in this video we're going to talk
about the process of glycolysis which is
a 10 step enzymatic process and a key
aspect of the glucose metabolism before
jumping into all of these 10 step
enzymatic reaction let us try to get an
overview that why this pathway is
important and which biological context
or metabolic context it is important so
we know that we have many options in our
diet like carbohydrates protein fat etc
and this kind of give us the calorific
input right and both protein and
carbohydrate has a calorific value car
around 4 whereas fat has calorific value
more than that now if we have option for
carbohydrate our body would generally
metabolize carbohydrate and use it as a
primary source of energy and the key raw
material for glycolytic pathway is the
glucose well does this glucose come from
from the dietary carbohydrate let's say
you have it in a banana or a bread so it
would be digested in your intestine and
ultimately inside your intestinal lumen
there would be cells the intestinal
epithelial cells which would uptake the
glucose or any monosaccharide form which
has been which has been bare in the
intestinal lumen after the digestion
with the help of several transporter for
example in case of glucose the sodium
dependent glucose transporter uptake the
glucose now once the glucose is in the
bloodstream it can enter several
different cell depending upon which type
of transporter is present in the cell
now let's say the glucose is inside of
one cell and now let's see what is the
fate of these glucose how this glucose
can be used by that particular cell to
generate energy and that is the process
of glycolysis so glucose would be
converted to several intermediates and
at this moment let us not bother about
these intermediates but let's say
glucose 6-phosphate
glycerol the height free phosphate these
are few of these important intermediates
ultimately the
eight of the glucose is to make apart
from pyruvate there would be other
products which would be produced in this
glycolic glycolic pathway such as nadh
and ATP so already you can see the
glycolytic pathway is important to
generate ATP further this pyruvate would
be entering the mitochondrion format
format of acetate and this acetyl coil
can be used to generate ATP in format of
Krebs cycle and then the electron
transport chain so we understand that
how glucose could be utilized in
glycolytic pathway then the krebs cycle
and electron transport chain to generate
ATP but let's say our body is in I mean
high supply of ATP and we have too much
of ATP at this situation what you don't
need for the production of ATP
so this glycolytic pathway is now
channeled in two different pathways in
order to if I mean maximize the
efficiency of these kind of pathways so
the glucose 6-phosphate which is a
glycolytic intermediate can be diverted
into pentose phosphate pathway giving
rise to NADPH which would be further
used in several anabolic processes such
as fatty acid biosynthesis glucose
6-phosphate can also be converted or
diverted towards glycogen it
glycogenesis pathway where glucose is
converted to glycogen
I mean glycogen is the fix deposit for
glucose now glycogen would be stored in
the muscle and liver so depending upon
the energy status of the body this kind
of glycolysis reaction can be or the
glycolytic intermediates can be diverted
to several processes and that's how our
body maximizes its metabolic pathways
depending upon energy demand now let's
say in starved state this same glycogen
would be broken down from the muscle and
the liver and that would be the primary
source of energy it would again of go
into the glycolytic pathway and from
energy
in fact our brain uses glucose as a
primary source of energy because fatty
acid and protein cannot pass the
blood-brain barrier whereas glucose can
easily pass the blood-brain barrier and
it can also ketone bodies can pass the
blood-brain barrier and that's why
glucose could enter the brain and work
like a primary source of energy
glucose undergoes glycolysis kreb cycle
all inside the brain cells and give it
energy and that's what keep us going
right now in case of cancer cell which
are rapidly dividing and their shows
uncontrolled growth they have a urge to
divide and they need huge amount of ATP
for rapid division and how does that it
become and imagine all this Krebs cycle
and all these etc' all this can happen
under aerobic condition but in a tumor
cell which is deeply inside a tumor core
it is in a hypoxic situation not getting
oxygen from the blood vessels because
the blood vessel might not be entering
so deep inside the tumor under that
hypoxic situation glycolysis is the
pathway which gives the tumor cell
energy or the ATP not these Krebs cycle
or the e.t.c so that's why tumor cell
primarily depend upon the glycolytic
pathways for energy and this effect is
known as Warburg effect in different
videos we would be talking about these
Warburg effect so glycolysis is the key
source of energy for rapidly dividing
cells such as cancer cell apart from
cancer cell stem cells also use the same
method to produce rapid energy and that
really helps them to divide now it is a
10 step process and several enzymes are
involved in this process so let's just
not get into too much detail in the
enzymatic reactions so let's just first
look at the important steps two steps
you can see that ATP is invested or its
investment but ATP is utilized and in
later on ATP is generated in further two
steps right so these two steps are known
as payoff phase and first two steps are
investment phase
in the beta phase where 1 3
bisphosphoglycerate get converted to 3
phosphoglycerate and phosphoenolpyruvate
gets converted into pyruvate these are
known as substrate level phosphorylation
because all of these cases ADP is
converted to ATP taking the phosphate
group from the substrates about
substrate level phosphorylation we're
going to talk about separately in a
different video but for now we had a
quick overview of glycolysis so if you
liked this video give it a thumbs up
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
thank you